قامت تركيا بعمليات عسكريه عديده في سوريا
والعراق وقالت انها تهدف لحمايه امنها
القومي
ومحاربه ما تصفه بالارهاب في الثامن عشر
من ابريل لسان الماضي اعلن تركيا عن
عمليات عسكريه اطلقت عليها قفل المخلب ضد
عناصر حزب العمال الكردستاني شمالي العراق
2019 جنه القوات التركيه على الحدود
السوريه التركيه اطلقت عليها عمليه نبع
السلام بهدف انشاء منطقه امنه عند مثلث
الحدود التركيه
العراقيه في العشرين من يناير كانون
الثاني من العام 2018 قام الجيش التركي
بعمليه عسكريه اطلق عليها غصن الزيتون في
مدينه عفرين الحدوديه شماليه سوريه بهدف
تحصيل امن تركيا القومي وبهدف تسليم
المدينه لاهلها حسب انقره 24 من اغسطس اب
من العام 2016
اطلقت انقر عمليه عسكريه بهدف دعم فصائل
المعارضه السوريه لطرد تنظيم الدوله من
منطقه الشمال السوري ثم توسعت لتشمل ابعاد
المقاتلين الاكراد الى شرق نهر الفرات